we've been using for about two
years in production um and
we've kind of grown tremendously in the
last year or so we've been like sharded
for about
10 12 months without kind of scaling up
vertically uh we collect billions of
different data points each month we'll
kind of get into some of the analytics
that we do but i'm going to give you a
summary of some to be collecting to
teach you a bit about how to do that in
london
so real quick before i do that i just
want to tap that boy and talk to you a
bit about what appoi is
so apple is a mobile relationship
management platform for mobile apps
basically what that means is we want to
help our customers people who have
mobile apps with their the engagement of
their users and we do that through a
three-step approach the first part is
understanding what your users do inside
your app tracking the behavior kind of
analyzing what's going on there from
there we allow our customers to segment
their users based on that behavior based
on their behavior in the app their
demographics or their social network
activities and then from there right
away for our customers to target users
for automated messaging and we do we
have a multi-channel approach through
push notifications emails and multiple
types of internet messaging so real
quick i'll show you so
real quick i'll talk about like uh use
case that we have a lot of customers do
customer onboarding so i have uh three
of our customers here urban outfitters
tex plus which is a popular text
messaging app and a shade magazine and
approach has an in-app messaging product
that we call our newsfeed which allows
our customers to send down
basically like facebook feed style
content into their app but targeted at
users based on their behavior so one
very popular campaign type that our
customers run is customer onboard so you
can see that each of these cards here
represent a different message and our
customers do a trip onboarding campaign
meaning that what they want to do is
send a message to you on day one of you
using the app and then on day three send
you another message and then on day five
send another message and then maybe on
day 10 or day 14 based on your activity
in the app you might get either message
a or b following after that that's a
really popular campaign for your
customers run on apple and the analytics
that we collect help us be able to push
that out
so
more formally i'll talk a bit about the
agenda the first thing i want to talk
about is how we store time series data
inside tv
and go big into flexible schemas
flexible schemas are really a huge
selling point and and great advantage to
so i'll talk to you about how you
can take advantage of that to store
analytics like time series data and talk
about breakdowns and then lastly
i'm going to switch topics to get into
something a little more exciting which
is statistical analysis on top of
when you have a lot of data
so i mentioned that mapwork collects a
lot of data under the hood for our
segmentation engine so i'll talk to you
about some of the analytics that we
track and examples of it and then we'll
go into examples of how we store this so
one of the things that we track is time
series
time series data is very easy to
quantify it's basically just some data
point and time value you can see a stock
chart here at tesla hopefully you bought
it in like somewhere around there
um but like examples of things that we
collect app opens over time amount of
revenue over time any kind of event over
time like our customers with text plus
text messaging app tracks how many text
messages are sent through their app um
yesterday
and then i mentioned that we have these
messaging options that close the email
we want to track the efficacy of that
how many emails are being sent today how
many of you open how many are balancing
how many posts are being sent et cetera
so there's lots and lots of things to be
broken down in time series following the
one time series there's a lot of
breakdown data that we want to show
basically represented as pie charts
things like device types operating
systems
revenue by product etc
and the interesting thing about
breakdowns is that we actually really do
care about this by time as well and the
reason is that you could look at say
operating systems if you want to track
from the beginning of time all the
breakdowns of operating systems in your
app you're probably going to have a lot
of ios 4 or ios 5 and ios 6 but really
it's probably a better representative
sample to take maybe the last say 90
days or 120 days where you'll see what
operating systems your customers using
so break down your lifetime series and
then you care about that over time
the last bit of analytics that we track
and then i'm going to go into
these segmentation and statistics about
that so i mentioned before that our
customers use us to identify what their
customers are doing in the app and based
on my behavior segment them into groups
and so example groups could be users who
use my app for more than five days where
users have spent more than five dollars
in my app for users who have not used my
app in over two weeks we call those
groups of users a segment and there's a
lot of questions that we want to know
about those segments how big is that
segment how many people have stopped
using miami for two weeks we want to
know how many of those users we can
reach how many have email addresses on
files how many have pushed uh are
pushing on their device how much money
does that group spend on average how
much money um does the paid user have i
don't know there's lots of statistics
around that that are interesting that
i'll get into how you can track that uh
later down the line
so the first thing i want to talk about
is a use case of time series data going
into pre-aggregated analytics tracking
opens over time does anyone here track
time series data by chance yes do i have
some t-shirts
now anyone who raises their hand
permanently
so
a typical time series collection uh that
you can see this in any kind of database
technology relational database is
basically going to have a timestamp
and then some identifiers so very very
implementation you can see here you log
a new row piece of data comes in and
then if you wanted to find
the
number of app opens you have a certain
date you can just do this this query to
look at how many how many opens did this
app have after some data
this extremely easy easy schema to put
together
on day one i mean and it's pretty
extensive you can like add attribution
you could add a user id you know device
id you can add all sorts of other things
there so you can kind of track these
data points
but if we want to show time series
charts it's not that big of a schema and
the reason is that you have one document
for data point and i imagine adverse
tracking billions of data points each
month it's really not going to be very
feasible for us to aggregate that all up
you really only care about this data in
advocate
um
also if you guys are used to tv
you might know that
because it keeps documents um
memory and it flushes the disk every so
often about once a second or every 100
milliseconds there's a difference
and if you create a lot of records dirty
a lot of pages don't have to be flush
with the disk and so it can actually
hurt your performance to make a lot of
sporadic updates um
maybe you're logging a point like this
but it all your mileage you can vary
based on your setup there so let's kind
of improve on this with aggregation so
what variation is going to do is we're
going to roll up this data into a time
that we care about so at boy we show
time series charts by hour so we'll
start there and kind of roll this up on
an hour and i'll show you what that will
look like so you change the document
here to group by a time period you can
see that i still have my app id but now
i have a date and then an hour and then
the number of opens per hour
and what you want to do is every time a
new app open happens you just find the
app idm date and then you just increment
the count of the app so what happens is
you end up having about 24 documents
every day
and it's really easy to then take these
documents and draw histogram because
each app each document is already
pre-aggregated for you
so the prone is super simple the con
though is that
if we store a document by hour we don't
really care about it by an hour then uh
mongo's data modeling principles uh
could say that this should probably be
something that's embedded
but additionally kind of what goes with
the con that i mentioned here is that
really kind of all program analytics is
we start to lose attribution
so if you saw on this on my previous
slide i said it was very easily easy to
extend with user id or device id
we're losing azure basically throwing
the ability for us to do that out of the
window
because there's no good place for us to
kind of put these user ids for the
website is here so
that's kind of a con of any pre-related
strategy that we talked about in a bit
so as i mentioned we don't want to look
at hours by themselves so let's kind of
embed them so to speak with hong kong
this is super easy we can create now a
document by day and kind of jump up a
level so i've changed this a bit now
i've got the app by getting the date the
same what i've got i have 25 of the
fields now i have 24 fields that
represent each hour of the day you're
going to have a total
count and then every time an app open
comes in what you want to do is
increment the hour that it happened and
the total count and what this gives you
is one document per day which is a very
low docking account if you wanted to
look at the number of like the time
series of the last 30 days it's only
pulling 30 documents from from
which is very fast to do
having the total number of opens up here
by day also allows you to do aggregation
framework
calculations on top of it if you wanted
to easily look at the number of tokens
per year or per month or whatever you
want very very simple to do that in one
query
it'll also be pretty fast much like all
the other prerogated strategies i talked
about or schemas i mentioned earlier
this should basically remain in memory
because what will happen is that we
expect this as soon as this document
gets created it'll be in the working set
in and the working set means that
it is already in mongo's memory and
updates which should be very fast
because they're going to happen in
memory
you do targeted or you enable targeted
marketing right
hunters and users so if you do this
you're losing user information how do
you do that well so as i mentioned the
pre-aggregation you lose attribution but
right now i'm just talking about time
series data all i want to do is show
charts i haven't
yet thought about how we're going to
show
target users based on their behavior
that's kind of the secret sauce behind
what we do but this sort of pattern is
very it's used a lot of that voice for
us to just show the time series data i
mentioned app opens over time events
over time purchases over time etc
anytime we want to show a chart like
that we can pre-aggregate that and not
have to go through the billions and
billions of data points that we have
so there's a downside to that schema
that i had which is that
it's pre-aggregated
but there's no good way to look at all
the dimensions if i want to look at the
app opens by device like what what are
the applicants on ipad or the applicants
on the ipod
or on different different platforms that
schema doesn't really do it
so
how would you do that in manga any
guesses
and drive shirts
similar so you can kind of look to
embedding documents the way that we do
it is using a great property of manga
with flexible schemas probably exactly
what you're thinking so check out this
this schema here
what we're going to do is
we're going to dynamically add fields to
the document as data comes in so you
look at this document here we've got
it's very similar to what i last had
you've got the app id and the date and
then you've got a totals count and then
you've got you would have 24 other
fields for hours 0 1 2 et cetera but
each of these now is an embedded
document that we can break down by
whatever
dimension that we want you can see here
that i've broken this down by devices
and so anytime an app open comes in what
we can do is look at all the dimensions
that we care about and generate one
update query to say update the totals if
it came in on ipad air we can update
this if it came in from a mail user we
can update this
and now it's very very easy for us to
look at app opens by any kind of
dimensional breakdown
so there's some pros and cons to this
just like any other approach
the pros that is very easy to add other
dimensions
as i showed you you had we had gender
and then we also had device type if you
wanted to add screen resolution
whether or not there was a pain user or
non-pain user very easy to do that
dynamically it's still going to be very
fast using one document per day so if
you grab those documents back and are
sharing it on the web form imagine that
you had a drop down and you could choose
the dimension you don't have to recreate
the database because that's already back
from you already have all that data
there you don't need to make any further
groups and then the benefit the thing
that i did i hate this entire time is
you get the breakdowns for free so
remember there's that pie chart that i
was showing that has an operating system
version or if you wanted to show like
device type you already have that you
can just look back on the schema and you
can see you have the devices you have
the number of opens on them you just
kind of look at that to generate your
breakdown so you don't have to have
another document so it's a really useful
property of this kind of aggregated
document
now the cons
this is kind of brought up in a question
is that you have no attribution at all
these documents so irrigation is not
really a great strategy as your only
analytic strategy you just use it as an
optimization for say drawing charts or
getting fast answers to questions like
how many app opens did we have yesterday
how many apple opens that we have this
month very easy for you to do even as
your data set grows to billions and
billions of app opens per month you
still have one document per day that can
answer all those questions you can keep
getting those responses back in constant
time no matter how large your data goes
but a real big problem of varigate
analytics too is that you have to know
your questions ahead of time
so as i showed you on the last slide we
talked about the device breakdown and
gender breakdown well
what if we wanted to graph by each group
what we have to do
where we have to add kind of go back to
the schema
go back to the screen we have to update
our app code to start pre-aggregating
binary
but the downside to that is that we
wouldn't have any historical data so if
i wanted to push out
a breakdown by revenue here in this app
and i coded that up today and i pushed
it to production tonight it's only going
to start collecting data tonight so all
the time series charts that we already
had
don't get that dimension so you kind of
have to know those questions ahead of
time for you to be able to
take advantage of prepared data data but
that can be okay based on what you're
trying to
achieve um so just in summary about
freedom data analytics before i close it
out it makes tracking time series data
very easy you get the breakdowns
you can add dimensions it's very very
easy to do but as i said i wouldn't rely
on this for your whole analytics
solution
you don't have any attribution you can't
ask ad-hoc queries about things that you
haven't thought about so it's really not
a great solution as you're only analytic
so does anyone have any questions before
i move on to segmentation
yeah the assumption is you store
individual data
yes
you should do that so could you
do ways on
oh i wanna
now i want to collect something like
this or i've already gotten an
individual record from located
through
your single date
of per day
you've got to feel in your individual
records that you weren't able to
so
if i understood you correctly the
question was if you have the ohm that
you're not already reactivating and you
want to start pre-aggregating that is it
easy to start creating
is that well can you you go back and you
go back in time
so you can go back to time
if you keep track of all the individual
data points
ideally what you want in a this is kind
of diverging from this this talk ideally
what you want in a big data setup is
something called lambda architecture and
lambda architecture what that means is
you have some some system that has
pre-computed very fast lookups on data
that you care about you've stored all
your data in a way that you have
that you have the ability to make an
arbitrary
function call on top of it you can think
of something like hadoop
um hadoop you stored all your data into
it you could run an arbitrary hadoop job
that could pull your data back and then
start pre-aggregating that so what you
do is you have something that
that ideally is fast but you can still
answer any question you want so if you
want to start back populating it you can
do that so i'm a huge proponent of you
not throwing any data away i don't think
there's any analytics company ever that
would say that you should throw data and
drop it on the floor
but if you're interested in drawing time
series charts on your website
that can be very fast this is a great
technique that i think is very useful
any other questions
cool
all right so um
next thing that i want to go into if i
can figure out which keys up and down
is
how apoy does user segmentation but
really how we do statistical analysis to
count quickly
so i'll go and just find what user
segmentation is with a screenshot from
our demo account that's available on
github
so this is a segment of users and the
segment of users the way we define it is
a group of users in your app that meet
some criteria so i'm not sure if you can
read this but here we've got push
enabled is true
age is older than 18 and country is the
united states
and appboy by default has about 20
dimensions on which you can add filters
and then you can log us event data
and then segment so you have sports apps
that keep track of their users favorite
players and they look at customers whose
favorite players lebron james
we have other other people who
like our text messaging app uses this
for example to look at countries that
people have called
and when we calls like the philippines
that was actually a campaign they sent
out last week
that they can just do using your simple
ui
and then on top of this we have some
data we have the total number of users
which in our sample apps only about 10
000. we can see that adding these three
filters means that we only select 501
users 420 of which are emailable but all
501 of them are pushable and the average
revenue per person is about 10 11 cents
so the talk about counting quickly
is because
i'm sorry what's that so this last
metric is average revenue per paying
user
so everyone who has paid that set
so the the the secret sauce boy is that
we show you this segment membership in
real time you can add edit remove
filters you can kind of tweak around a
bit we'll update those statistics
in real time and we do it in what i call
web speed so i'm just going to clarify
this here
real time you might think of as to the
millisecond but when you're on the
website you're tinkering with some
analytics and you change your value and
it tosses off a spinner how long do you
care
that like that you have to wait at what
point you get annoying anyone
sorry i don't know if you said that i'm
gonna just throw this this way
so yeah okay 10 15 seconds good we think
it's like four
so we try to aim to make sure that it's
like you know not much more than four
seconds preferably
way faster than that but that's kind of
what we're gonna target and kind of how
i talk about we do this quickly
so the way we do this quickly is we
estimate
for that sample app that i showed you
that only had 10 000 users you know
we're going to be destinated it's it's
not very hard to scan that
collection but we have apps on our
platform that have millions or tens of
millions of monthly active users and we
want to do it for them just as fast as
we do it for the people who have ten
thousand
so my goal again is i
count quickly but the problem as you saw
is we have all these filters we don't
get to control
what the user puts in they have 20
dimensions that we provide and then they
can log arbitrary data to us and filter
based on that so the thing is i have an
arbitrary query that i want to get
statistics about
and the problem is that tv counts
are really slow especially on index ones
for those of you who haven't experienced
this or aren't yet using mongodb mongodb
uses memory map files so anytime it's
going to touch a file it's got a page
that is memory if you're going to scan
like a document
collection that has 10 million documents
you're going to put all those 10 million
dollars remember that's going to take a
lot of time and push out some other
things out of your working set it's not
really going to be the best thing for
you to do on a frequent basis
so let's go into this as an example
let's say i have 10 million documents
that represent people they've got
someone who's got a favorite color blue
he's 27 he likes pizza and i have a lot
of questions that i want to ask
about this data set these 10 million
dollars i'm wondering how people like
blue how many people live in new york
city and love pizza how many men have a
shoe size greater than 10.
so the big question is how would you
estimate accounts
and the solution is going to be that
we're going to do
the exact same thing
that the news numbers do
we're going to estimate it using
statistics
anytime a news network says that they
think that bill de blasio's gonna win
with 65 percent confidence or whatever
they say
they didn't ask every new yorker right
they asked like a couple of new yorkers
and then they tried to figure it out
when they want to
figure out which president is going to
win the election they'll ask all
americans you just ask a few they run
some formulas they take some samples and
then they're able to give you an answer
plus or minus some percentage we want to
do the exact same thing
all right so let's kind of delve into
what we would do so the first thing we
do if we had this data set is let's just
add a random number
to every single document and i'm going
to put it in some known range and say
it's between 0 and
999. so that's 10 000 random numbers i'm
going to put on every dot and every time
it gets inserted
one document's going to have a random
number on it and i'm going to put index
on it so that way i can kind of search
that that collection pretty quickly
so the first step that i want to do is
get my random sample
just like the news network to do and
they call up random people and they ask
them questions i want to do something
simple so i've got 10 million documents
and i have 10 000 random buttons
so what i would expect each bucket
should hold about a thousand users so if
i look at all the users who have a
number one two three it should be bad at
that all the users who have nine
thousand should be mad at that
five six seven should be about any
number you pick between zero and nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine you
expect it to be about a thousand users
in there
so
now what we'll do is we'll get our
random sample um what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna take a random hundred thousand
users and that's what we're gonna look
at so we can take a random range that
holds all those so remember each bucket
holds a thousand users so if i want a
hundred thousand users i should look at
about a hundred buckets i can also
choose this randomly um just to keep
keep with the fun so any of these kind
of buckets work i can go from zero to
101 i can go five over three to seven
four i can even wrap around going from
nine nine five five all the way to 56
so that's what we're going to do
and has an operation or an
operator called max scan that you can
use to tell only scan this number
of objects so just to be safe in case
you don't have thousand users per bucket
we're going to max scan that put it 100
so once we have our sample size we're
going to learn a little bit about it so
here's what we're going to do we're
going to look at this random size this
is a gram sample for all the males who
like blue another shoe size greater than
10. we're gonna max scan it to a hundred
thousand and then has a command
called explain that will show you what
the query did
how many documents it looked at what
index it used how many things matched it
how many times you yielded there's a lot
of data you can get out of there but we
only care about two things two outputs
one is called n scan objects which is
going to tell you how many documents
it's scanned
another is n which is going to tell you
how many documents match the criteria so
if you look at this you see that we
scanned 100 000 random documents
and about 11 000 of the match
so here's just now
you just take the population sample size
it matches that's about 11.3 percent now
go to google and you type in sample size
calculator what you do is you can find
the calculator that allows you to enter
these three things and spits out that
it's plus or minus zero point two
percent given a ninety-five percent
column so we do that exact same thing
and then we actually put it at the
bottom of that segment page it says we
give them the confidence interval and we
tell them how confident we are
so there are then some things that you
want to do to optimize um there's some
other cheats if you're sharded you can
actually max scan to 100 000 divided by
the number of shards you have because
otherwise i'm assuming that you're going
to query all shards scanning so many
users like this um that'll be even
faster than that you can catch the
random range this is a great property of
that it has is that once documents
are in memory it's very fast to do
queries on it so say you like
technically load up a random 100 000
users into mongo's memory any subsequent
questions you want to ask about it
you could expect to be way faster than
the first question which might have had
to page things in its memory so all
those users can sit there on our
dashboard they can tinker with mail
email
you know likes pizza like sushi or
whatever they can change all those
values and they should be even faster
than their first result
um there are other optimizations you can
do like adding more ram to making sure
that your working set or as much as you
can
stays in memory and
100 users doesn't knock out other
important things of your working set
and then there's some some other
keys you can do to cache results and not
hit the database again if i'm going
between male and female and male and
female just to look at what the
difference was you don't want to hit the
database there's some other cool things
you can do you can also cache partial
results such some queries don't even
have a database at all but that's a
little more advanced and then lastly you
can kind of group on this you get more
than one count the thing that i showed
you just was how to get the number of
users that match that query but remember
that we want to know other things how
many of them can we reach by email how
much money do they spend how many can we
do via push um so you can use the
aggregation framework on top of this to
get more answers to your questions um so
once you start getting into here there's
going to be a lot of manga bugs that you
run into so um buyer beware this stuff
like the the depths of this scale
and stuff can get a little complicated
um because explain also i probably
would not put that into production
because
it's not a standard operator it's more
of a debugging tool and also then you
can run it to queries that hit things
like multi-heat indexes that put
for wrenches in in your
in your operation here so anyone who
gets to the stage if you have any
questions i'm more than happy to go and
decide how we work around some of these
mango bugs to get this going
so real quick just to summarize is kind
of getting to get into the talk uh we
first talked about pre-aggregate
analytics um the way that you you do
this is you create a document that
represents event occurrences and time
period and the document itself is kind
of rolled up to a time period that you
care about and this takes full advantage
of mango's flexible schema so you can
add all sorts of dimensions that you
want to it and remind that this is not a
catch-all please store all your data do
not throw data away ever
and then from there we talk about trying
quickly you can estimate the results of
arbitrary queries using a sample size
and depending on your app this could be
great when we have customers that have
tens of millions of objective users if
i'm off by
plus or minus 0.2 percent i don't really
care i'm just trying to show to them
dashboard so it's a great application
for us to do it but of course your
application could
vary from that so that's all i've got i
have three more t-shirts and random
sizes if you guys have any other
questions on anything i talked about
here
right here
let's say you want to keep track of
averages and
how long
yeah i mean that's kind of where you
start running like so the question was
do every framework is good for keeping
track of some of these things like
counts but if you want to keep track of
averages or medians
you can kind of run into some pitfalls
there
so
um that's some territory that we
tinkered with a little bit and we
haven't used the aggregation framework
for it
we've taken our sample size we've used
raw mango driver to in a background
thread another worker uh or another
server even run some of that data and
then push it back to our application
layer so we kind of split up some of the
statistics so you saw in our dashboard
here
nope you did not see it
sorry for this
you saw here that you have all these
statistics
we've experimented with adding better
statistics that are more computational
intensive and then having like a spinner
by this so maybe all these six
statistics load first and then we have
other statistics underneath it that
loaded individually that we take up with
background processing that gets
secondary databases that we can afford
to be a little more computationally
expensive because the thing is remember
i'm optimizing for web ski i want our
customers to tinker with filters see how
this changes if this data comes back in
two seconds and then this data comes
back three seconds later yes so yeah
yeah so like what do you do in terms of
collecting data on the actual devices
are you um are you kind of
logging it and then just periodically
sending it up i mean i'm just concerned
about how chatty you could be from
you mean in terms of our like sdk that
sits on the mobile device yeah mobile
device you know it's not constantly
sending up data right so yeah so so i
didn't even talk about this but
you know the gentleman here assumes what
would be true is that um appoint has a
mobile app sdk that goes inside your app
if you have an ios app or an android app
you put or sdk and you log event data
and we try to not be super chat because
spinning up the network radio is
it's very expensive on the devices you
don't want to kill the battery so we we
take advantage of a couple different
things we opportunistically like on
android we have way more control of what
we do you can opportunistically um send
out packets up when you know that the
radio is already being used um we queue
data to not send it up uh very you know
immediately after you send it so there's
a lot of optimizations that we've tried
to do to keep make sure that we're not
impacting your apps battery life
if anyone has any questions about app
boys as a product
i have plenty of business cards and can
get you a t-shirt mailed to you
across data centers within the same
cluster and if yes how does it really
perform so the question was if i've used
tv across data centers
that's something we haven't ventured
into
and i'm a little afraid of when we get
there
so don't have a good answer for you but
now we're going to mention it
yes you just do anything where you
provide discoloration data for custom
filters
i'm sorry i started there for custom
filters so can i draw a graph based on
the custom filters that i create
um so
because this is just a spot right yes so
this goes back to the the thing about
prairie data analytics knowing the
questions
let's say you create this segment
of users who are pushing able for older
than 18 to 11 united states and you want
to look at their applicants over time
the problem is you can't do it using
aggregation
for historical data
if we took advantage of that if we had
that feature on our dashboard which we
don't get
and we wanted to use variegated
analytics that would be a downside
because remember with pre-advocated
analytics you have to know the question
ahead of time so i can't start tracking
whether or not users who are opening the
app or in this segment until i've
created a segment
and then going forward i can track it
that we've thought about and we haven't
pushed it out yet
um we think it's probably acceptable for
our customers to
accept that yeah for us say you know you
create the segment and then moving
forward you'll see it you create a
segment and a week later you're not
going to care because you'll have all
the answers you want um so for our
application that sort of thing can work
that does not work for all applications
google analytics though did release that
where they allow you to create a segment
on your web property and then apply
historically and that's why google is
fantastic
sorry yes
should uh watch out for the google plus
doing my first pocket
you can't paint using the
irrigation framework this is a real big
pain in the ass
so
for example i showed that where we had
the index on random you put an index on
random and one optimization that i think
i left off the slide is if you do it
exactly as i described it you're going
to want to hate that random index and
what hinting is for those of you who
don't know is you're going to tell
to use a specific index that you've
chosen if you don't do that is
going to try to run a lot of different
indexes all at the same time and pick
the winner and what happens is you're
going to end up you could end up if it
picks bad index scanning a lot of
documents so even though you think
you're scanning 100 000
you're not you're scanning way more
distinct documents than that you're just
doing it across all these components so
that's a big pain that you've had to
work around um
and then and then going from there
looking at any kind of the way that
longer treats multi-key indexes there's
a number of bugs that are open in jira
in terms of not being able to use
its multi index effectively um
there are like three or four different
classes of bugs and everything to go
into more detail but like you're you
kind of
there will be dragons here like when you
actually could actually like try to do
this um this is not like this is why our
secret sauce is so good um
it's hard to do but i i definitely look
out for not being able to hint the 16
megabyte size limit in is
extremely annoying um they're fixing
that though from 2.6 so you guys are not
going to be you're late
um
oh no the the results from each of the
pipeline operated or pipeline written
down on operators has to be 16 megabytes
because especially if you're in a
chartered environment you get things
that then kind of aggregate up to the
mongodb s to perform there that's my
understanding of it and if you go past
16 megabytes there it's just gonna fail
so there's parts of things that we try
to use the aggregation framework for and
then we added another pipeline operator
and said sorry you use more than
16 megabytes worth of
space we're just going to kill you and
you're like what
totally unreasonable they realized that
and they're fixing it
it's not out yet
um so with a great way to tell if
it's a blogger mouth log is explain
explain is there to help you know what
is mango doing
and then there's there's things that we
do we have a great support team we don't
host mongodb ourselves i would love to
but it's pretty complicated so i
outsourced that to a company called
optic rocket which then has a premium
sport contract with mongodb court so on
a number of occasions we've had to
escalate our issues up to object rocket
who didn't have to escalate it out to
mongodb um that they're here in new york
city is great we've gone in for office
hours on um
tomorrow we've gone in before we've sat
with the engineers and we talked through
what's bug and what's not bug or um if
we're doing something badly or not so um
taking advantage of the resources they
give you
it's a good way to figure out it
something that just happened to happen
yeah i mean you you could um
i kind of sympathize a little bit with
when i think about it because they
don't like these indexing problems they
feel like they don't know the relational
structure ahead of time especially a lot
of people who use kind of like
their ideas in your relational database
you have a user's clutch you have an
apps collection you have a devices
collection and they're all related right
users have devices devices have users
devices use apps etc
um is not always that good for that kind
of data um there were a few things that
drew us to manga
one was that i was really excited about
using technology because i just weighed
hedge fund and i really want to use my
stuff so
story of what you know probably
so i wanted to try it out um
we were working on a problem that was
unrelated to this that was similar to a
problem that foursquare had talked about
and we were like a fourth grader uses
pongo maybe we'll try that out um
and then we've kind of expanded on this
um
being able to do the fast queries in
memory
has been a huge boon when we were early
on we were like should we switch off
and go on something else and we
did speed tests and for some of the
queries that we were thinking we would
make which we then later some of them we
made some that we didn't it ended up
being pretty good and in some cases a
lot faster like the time series data
really approval you can do some of that
like pre-aggregation using stored
procedures and transactions in a
relational database but that flexible
schema stuff that you get it's just dead
simple for us to do something like that
so
and then the segmentation stuff i mean
literally
i went to
pre-op training i went to
long beach beat stuff i i tried some
postgrass like went to google bigquery i
tried
all sorts of stuff to say this is the
problem that i'm trying to solve i have
all these users that have all these
properties and i want to filter them by
an arbitrary number of arbitrary
properties um
and i didn't have a really good solution
and this was the best thing i could get
that was pretty fast
hey yeah this is too big for me
i
any other questions